coming up next um you are going to
attract if you attract trash around you
all the time and there's probably
something wrong with you is it my
responsibility to see any different than
how you portray yourself of course not
it's just interesting because they'll
take a twerking class before they take a
cooking class we've absolutely hinge it
gives women the false perception that
they can that they're a higher value
than what they are I'm finding it hard
to understand how you have a
quote-unquote boyfriend yeah when you've
never met them in person and that is a
world where we're moving into a woman
will actually get literally like
emotionally involved literally through
words on a screen
let's get started um we're going to talk
about dating apps and whether it's
ruining dating or not folks um first of
all first question
is anyone here on a dating app and
has it been a negative or a positive
experience for you
when you see it on a dating app do you
mean like actively using it to find
something or just like you you just
happen to be you just have to you have
it downloaded which one is it I mean
you're using it you're active on it yeah
um now I'm not active on the dating apps
but um depending on the outcome you're
looking for
they're definitely beneficial depending
on the outcome you're looking for that's
key
do you think they're a bit more
beneficial for men than they are women
because you sounded like you you've had
like good time one day
I'm not gonna lie um the day and that's
make things a lot more simplistic again
depending on what your outcome is like
and I think different dating apps
um will obviously lead to different
outcomes for people so I think two of
the more prominent ones is probably
hinge and Tinder yeah like Tinder people
know today that Tinder is basically the
sex app I'd say hinge probably has a bit
more fruitful prospects for people
looking for a long-term relationship
however
again it's another place to go and have
fun if you're if you're a guy but also
for a girl I believe obviously at the
end of the day it's one that comes I'm
sleeping with women to get what I mean
so if if the girls are out there having
fun on those dating apps as well then I
guess it's beneficial for both again
depending on what you're looking for
okay
are you on dating apps oh are you in a
relationship no I'm in a relationship so
you're not on them at all no I've only
ever used dating apps twice
I've been on two dates in total from
those apps that I've used were they good
dates no not particularly and it wasn't
that I wanted to do it it was more like
you know your friends convinced you like
I'll try this out I'm like okay I'll try
but it was not really for me why not
um I'm more of a Vibes person so I
prefer the old school you meet someone
you get you feel their energy and then
therefore you see if you're gonna be
friends with them or you want to date or
you're attracted to them I feel like
people going for an Argos catalog of
faces yeah that's also based on people's
Aesthetics not necessarily what the
person's liking because that's not my
first thing that I go for when I'm
looking to date or be with someone
therefore it's not I don't feel like I
get much from looking at people's you
said that you were in like a female
relationship so did you go on the day
and app for both male and female or just
female I always go on for both okay yeah
which I think before you can do that on
appshire to be one or the other but
um yeah I've the both dates I went on
with guys one was from Tinder he was a
hatfish
um it was just a bit boring like he was
actually lovely guy sorry I don't what
happened oh that's that's like when a
guy takes up like he let's say he's an
eight but he took off his hat now he's a
five now he's got a receiving hairline
are you serious it wasn't that deep but
I just thought it was funny because I'd
heard someone use the terminology before
and I was like okay
why did you take it why was he different
when you so hang on let me get this
straight so you were on the app yeah and
what on the picture he had his hat on uh
yeah well I didn't clock all his
pictures he was wearing a sign he was
wearing the Hat in all the pictures well
obviously I don't frequent dating sites
so I didn't I didn't realize he was good
looking right
here yeah which is fine it was just yeah
and then when you met him he took his
hat off yeah he had really bad receding
hairline
it wasn't that deep but because as I
said it's not all about Aesthetics but
it shows you that people can portray
themselves online as something that
they're not and if you meet people in
person you're more likely to get a Vibe
about the person then I mean even for
like writing a profile the kind of
person I am people might see me and
assume I'm this way or that way but I'm
actually so many other things there's
not enough bio to write how you are as a
person I don't feel so you're more
likely to accept his his receding
hairline if you'd met him in person over
it was just like it's just an attraction
thing so I didn't find him as attractive
so um so for me and then the fact that
his energy wasn't really he was nice but
our energies didn't match it just felt
like it wasn't really it was a bit of a
waste of time so that was the first one
um yeah so okay are you on a date now uh
I have one downloaded but I'm not really
active on it if I'm honest I don't
really it's not ideal I like meeting
people in person like you say because
you get you get like a lot more from
them than just texting
um I think my situation I don't really
go out so I don't really meet anyone you
know like unless it's like on now I
don't I don't really meet people I don't
go out you know so it's not it's not
really
So when you say you don't go out does
that mean wouldn't dating apps be ideal
for you yeah that's what I'm saying they
are ideal but they're just long and
because it's so quick and because like
my situation I don't really get much
free time so you've got to keep talking
to these people sometimes a couple of
weeks do you see what I mean before I'm
free so the chances of them still
talking to me that when it's so quick
and it's just it's just a bit longer I'm
not the biggest fan of it if I'm honest
the thing is right I'm of a different
generation okay and when I was growing
up to me dating apps
was basically the Lonely Hearts column
yeah 100 like black with these have like
the Lonely Hearts column newspapers so
when I look at dating apps I'm like are
people really that lonely that they've
got to go to uh
insecure sorry okay I'm curious um has
any of you ever had a relationship
develop from a dating app like a
long-term one no no
no so I I'm I've never I've never been
on it I've never been on a dating app
okay I've never been on one time but I
have to add though I also use the dating
apps for recruitment purposes as well
because that's a great place to meet
people who are yeah it's a network as
well so you know him
so I think the difference with when I
first when I used Tinder that was like
my friends convinced me I'd gone for a
breakup just try and go on a date okay
cool didn't like it right and that was
fine hinge I found was more
um something that I'd find more
beneficial for me because you get more
of a profile about the person it asks
you are you a smoker do you like raving
do you go out do you have any pets these
are like it's more like a social profile
right and people can ask questions so
you get more of a flavor for the person
so with a different dating apps like
different different purposes different
purposes and I think it's about being
clear about what you're trying to get
out of the situation previously if like
you said you're old school people used
to date or Court in order to get married
and be in stable long-term relationships
right now people are more is it short
term you want a day you want to friends
with benefit you want a sugar daddy you
want a husband like people are not clear
about what it is they're seeking
therefore
it's that I think that's why apps are
more prevalent now that's why you're
saying Eddie's saying that obviously
people go on apps and it's for if it's
Tinder maybe it's just a sexual thing
it's not necessarily for long term so
different apps come with different
nuances people are seek an arrangement
because I want a sugar daddy what do you
guys what do you guys think of this stat
unpopular dating apps Tinder
women swipe right 14 of the time where
men swipe right 46 of the time
so swiping right means that yeah that's
a yes you've liked and then the person
swipes right as well then you get a
match well then I I basically think I
think that's that's hypergamy on
steroids isn't it like I've always said
like hypergamy right now as I'm steroids
and I think women are looking for the
the literal ideal man which is probably
why they swipe right 14 of the time men
uh we're not that picky a lot of the
time like it was like ah she looks okay
it's fine I think it's a cheat code it's
a cheat code for one for the woman to to
get access to the type of man that she
desires whereas for a guy it's just easy
to
to do the numbers game where I can I can
try and get as much as possible as much
volume as possible in the shortest time
that I can
um
so yeah people people getting lost in it
in reality it's like a picking mix now
who do you think it's more beneficial
for um an average woman or a top tier
man who gets more benefit out of a
dating app it's definitely a top tier
man top tier but at the same time the
benefit the benefit is is easy access to
fix it I think it's what what dating
apps do is it plays into a man's
biological imperative which is just to
like scatter his seed tastes like you
get far more access to to women if
you're a Gaba certain caliber as we know
women only swipe right a small minority
of the time but if you're able to
portray enough of the characteristics
that women are are into then you have a
massive access to a massive pool of
women that's just easy to slay like look
at them to the Tinder Swindle as a
perfect example yeah it is so there is
um someone in the chat said 60 of
married people used to meet at work in
the U.S and now 60 of married people
meet on dating apps that is actually
crazy
times though isn't it I suppose people
are busy now it's just easier what's
worse with that is that I think the
people who meet on dating apps only last
an average of like five years in a
marriage whereas people who meet at work
it's an average of 10 or more yeah but
do people go once it's like five is
around the average length of email yeah
it's like five they start that they get
divorced by seven it's like do people go
on dating apps to find long-term
relationships do you guys think yes some
people do I know one of my friends got
married and they've got two kids they
they met on a dating app what what app
was it do you know it was Tinder really
yeah it was but she it was they had they
had messed oh don't because it's a
business but it yeah it was we don't
know yeah I know but still she um yeah
there was Tinder that they they had met
on
I think women would probably be way more
likely to look for something more
serious
um than men would what I've noticed that
hinge do is that you have a section
where you can say are you like are you
looking for a long-term relationship or
short-term yeah relationship the weird
thing about it is you will get a lot of
girls saying figuring out dating goals
or looking for short-term relationships
and I think that's quite interesting in
terms of what women Aspire for
um what they're looking for long term
because the reason why I'm asking that
has it ruined dating like
as it made as it made human interaction
um a little bit more what we're looking
for frivolous like it's not it's not as
you know there's no meaning behind the
behind the connection it it is it's
belittled to what human interaction
means because it it takes away a lot of
the necessary things that would make a
meaningful interaction because now it's
a case of like I said it's a picky mix
whereas before the guy who had the dead
hairline might have been a guy who was
appealing based on how he came across
because he'd learned how to communicate
with other people whether it's now these
guys are Savvy on texting and then in
person they're just [__] yeah right so
you've they've lost the importance of
active communication and that affects
long-term situations I agree with that I
think it's a sign of the times because
we're losing human interaction that's
such a fast rate it's actually scary so
we're doing so much we're looking at so
much time based on screen and you know
even when you go to the shops you no
longer go into a cashier you're using a
machine right we're getting so into like
losing that I think even if you look at
the younger generation they don't even
know how to effectively communicate or
have manners or hold a conversation that
is Meaningful because everything's so
based on internet and I also think that
that's set a standard or a precedent
that people are now very insecure
because people are not really living in
their truth so they're looking at this
than the other and then they're basing
their expectations as you're saying
about women having a high expectation of
this perfect man but does that even
exist but you're basing it on something
that's full of false pretenses because
you've seen on the Internet influencers
or models or do you see what I mean so
when we're looking at these things
people are then setting standards when I
don't think half those people are even
real so that's what that's done and
that's the interesting thing I think
with with apps like Tinder and hinge it
gives women the false perception that
they connected that they're a higher
value than what they are oh yeah because
having access to a certain caliber of
men even just a conversation
to a lot of women to lose them into
thinking that this is the type of man
that I can get this is what I'm worth
and then they end up sleeping this guy
but the reality is you know a woman is
judged but the man that she can keep not
by who she sleeps with
um so I think dating apps actually
deluded me into thinking that they have
a higher value than what they're
actually worth because when you say that
it's because like I've said before
um women have a hard time
differentiating between the certain
types of attention so if if a woman gets
attention she gets attention she loves
it but there are certain men that will
give you attention because they want to
smash 100 right and they're set a minute
make you you know they're long-term and
I think
um the reason why I'm asking like has it
ruined it because I'm just like women
are getting
loads of attention constantly on these
apps right and I think it's warping
their sense of reality do you know what
confuses me so like I I used to be on
dating apps I don't use them anymore but
this is just like from what I when I
used to use them and I remember speaking
to one girl on on the stating up and
she was like um
she was a um a twerk teacher
as you can imagine her her profile was
this food field of just booty I've seen
cheeks and I'm like yeah all right cool
so I've slid in there drop a little bar
here and there so now me and her talking
I've met this girl
and she was then upset it's like why the
guys always look at me for one thing
because you portrayed that yeah as a
twerking teacher not just a twerking if
you see what home girl was wearing not a
lot it was a Madness yeah and obviously
when I seen her
it was a similar situation yeah what do
you know what I mean so you saw her and
her cheeks were out cheeks was out and I
was thinking yeah
so she would she and obviously me I like
to have conversations obviously the way
we do podcasting we just like to talk
and understand your way of thinking
right so she's complaining why do men
always always see me for one thing and
you know why can't a guy just Overlook
my assets and just focus on me but I'm
just like don't you understand that what
you're portraying is what we're gonna
act upon well I've always said
everything is sales in this life
everything you sell so people are going
to ask you
um before you even before you even open
your mouth people are looking at you and
they're and they're wondering what
you're selling right and so if you see
constantly cheeks breasts
skimpy clothes you're gonna be like okay
I can see what she's selling so people
who say to themselves or say to you or
me and say oh why do guys only see me as
flesh It's like because well that's what
you're selling but the thing is it's
gone it's just interesting because
they'll take a twerking class before
they take a cooking class right relax
it's like you it's like you want to be
valued for something else but what have
you done to be valued for something else
I agree with that is it my
responsibility to see any different than
how you portray yourself of course not
because why should I see any differently
if you're gonna give me a certain
product which is what you're
representing right now right why do I
have to have the responsibility to see
any different than what you're giving me
that doesn't make no sense do you think
it's the same for guys do you think that
if a guy is like constantly got like his
top off and his app showing in his chest
showing do you think a guy feels the
same way like oh my God why are they
only viewing me for what I look like no
I think that guys do that because they
want to be viewed as that kind of Mel
that is yeah going out and he's that guy
is because they want to show you that
they're out there to they're that guy
they're the study guide they're going to
sleep with all the women and they're not
showing you that they want to be your
husband what's feminine it's like I
think it's kind of feminine when guys
take a lot of selfies and they're super
into appear like I don't know so a guy
topless on on the Internet is like it's
feminine you say I I'm not a fan of like
the shirtless pictures like I think
that's about gays though that's the
difference they I think they think that
we like that and you get that a lot in
exactly the same as on day and apps you
get a lot of men with kids so you're
looking at these kids there's nothing
over their face
that's just mad that it's just
unbelievable that they're happy and in
their head I'm sure they think the women
are going to love this
oh women do but I'm sorry if you're a d
if you've got a bit of something about
you you're looking at a man that's got a
kid their face out like I don't look at
that and think oh he's good
no yeah I've got some but I wouldn't put
his face on the [__] dating app
but the thing is women tend to lack that
stuff yeah it's a sign of pre-selection
so if a guy has a kid it signals to a
woman that someone else says yeah I get
that it's just it's just too much but I
feel like men if a guys commonly do
something it's probably because it works
so as much as I say like oh you know I'm
not a big fan of the shirtless selfies
they do it often it probably and it
works I wonder what saw women they're
attracting by doing that do you see what
I mean do they care
so I don't mean they do care but in the
long term if that's what they're used to
then when they want to come and look for
a partner and they've just been used to
getting their top off and getting some
action then they're going to be confused
I mean I think I think if they didn't
like the quality of girls they got
they'd probably stop doing it but it's
again we're going back to the not
looking for long-term Solutions they're
not looking for a long-term relationship
some people are seeking instant
gratification
relationships and long term this is
something interesting I'm trying to find
a torsa put in the chat when you're
talking about women that put short-term
on their profile she says that's a
mating strategy so she can get access to
the guys that are looking for short term
right so she's saying like it's the same
thing when guys say they want a
relationship when they just want
something oh okay because that's going
to attract them in yeah so it's like a
mating strategy okay so it's like okay I
say short term yeah but I really want
something at the moment like I'm trying
to lock him down right it's like being
ambiguous like the ones that say
figuring out dating goals I just want to
see where it goes like what do you think
Amanda to do with that information
I mean for me do you think women would
do it if it didn't work do you want do
that I I'm I don't know like could we
apply the same logic and say like women
do that because it works I think no it
must do because again it starts the
conversation with the guys they're
probably interested in but the reality
is is
the outcome by putting that the best
outcome for you and often the answer is
no but this is what I hate because in
that scenario women would then play the
victim like oh my God he did this and
they did that but it's like
you set the the foundations on on a
foreign
and it's like well if you are
put in that kind of stuff
as your on your profile right you're
gonna attract a certain type of man
you're over to attract if you attract
trash around you all the time and
there's probably something wrong with
you yeah and I don't think that's
controversial either but women it's like
I don't understand why it's so okay to
hate men
I was actually going to pull that point
out because part of what you will see a
lot on hinge is gone because on hinge
you can have the there's a question you
can answer the question yourself so some
of them will say um I'm a 10 Baht and
then put the butt away with the buyers
but one of the questions I often see is
prove to me that and then you will hear
the answer for the girl is men aren't
trash or all men aren't [__] or things
along those lines it's just blatant
misandry but it plays the plate of His
Banner I'd love to see if a man said
that through to me so you're saying that
in these dating apps um miss Andrew is
just like it's normal it's very normal
like you're seeing a lot of women's
profiles but it's misogyny then this is
normal well I can't I can't see the
guy's side so I can only assume that
um
they probably get canceled or that you
can report them I'm sure women they're
probably not answering on hinge you
don't have to answer all of the
questions so you you can make your
profiles like
long or short as you want and I don't
think the guys are answering all of
those long do you know what I mean
instead of keeping it basic I'm curious
have you guys
um ever had a relationship start from
being approached in person
yeah yeah
cold yeah cold approach yeah
you have
wasn't approaching a woman yeah yeah
it's got so speak
but that's the thing like do you guys
prefer that interaction that human
interaction or do you or do you prefer
the interaction via the screen no person
yeah human yeah but the thing is people
say that but there's less interaction
via humans the generation that as well
it's a different generation right now I
find that I've got Snapchat I'm not
really on Snapchat like that I've got
Snapchat ages ago because someone was
saying it's true that when certain
things happen in the world if you go on
the map and then you look at like the
hot spots you can see what's going on in
real life do you see what I mean that
that's why I like it for that aspect but
of course when you've got that profile
but people use like Instagram and
Snapchat as online dating it's just a
different sort of just different sort of
thing Instagram's the biggest thing you
know what's what's interesting for me
because
I've seen people say that they fell in
love with somebody right
from another place
on a screen they've never met the person
in real life like I so funny I knew this
girl
um previously not now
um
who had like a boyfriend quote unquote a
boyfriend that she'd never ever met in
person catfish in there you know it's
watching no no no no I'm not saying
she's catfish but that that is that
thing I I'm finding it hard to
understand how you have a quote unquote
boyfriend yeah when you've never met
them in person and that is a world where
we're moving into
because people romanticize the idea of
this because you see what screens allow
you to do is it allows you to fill in
the gaps so a lot of people will see
these guys online and you're not getting
the full story so it gives and if you
are really attracted to the game then it
allows you to say you know what I'm
gonna fill in the gaps with what I want
in the ideal man so it's all a form of
projection this is what I want from a
man he's got the looks already he talks
to me I'm Gonna Fill in the rest of the
gaps which are what what what all the
gaps he's a nice guy he probably loves
me he's probably selling another dream
over the phone that base I can't wait to
see you fully lives in France somewhere
yeah see what I mean literally just
sending her across your effort than it's
worth for the guy like you got to talk
to her for months then you've got to
think what type of guys it has got that
kind of time to yeah to do that and
that's that's the thing about the screen
going that far like why only doing it
close off why has he got to go because I
think it's I think it's easier to sell
women a dream over a screen 100 it's not
it's not easy to tell a guy a guy will
interact with a woman by the screen in
but a woman will actually get literally
like emotionally involved literally
through words on a screen do you know
what I mean I think like the the way in
which it's quite easy to sell women a
dream
um goes back to you know Disney movies
and rom-coms and all this kind of women
can see things on a screen and fall in
love with it and fall in love with an
idea yeah it's the fact because women
will always fall in love with what they
hear whilst men will fall in love what
they see right so it's easy to for a man
it's easy to have that kind of lustful
look for this beautiful woman but you
know because men are forced to have to
live in reality so you know this ain't
real you know that you know what this is
a fun interaction for what it is right
now but it's probably not going to go
anywhere I don't really care what the
situation is but for that woman you're
allowing her to live within a fairy tale
or you're feeding into that delusional
bubble that most women live in nowadays
it's like you know like that Disney
fairy tale the outcomes you know I'm
gonna meet my prince charming he's gonna
fly over and we're gonna go we're gonna
have a great time
guys I have a crazy question torsha you
are killing it right now is it wrong
from man to report fraud after a date
with a woman who didn't disclose that
she was trans
oh my God
that's not a woman so yeah it's fruits
could you argue that that's also if
anything sexual happens that that's
sexual or s-a yes yes yes if if I've
gone into a situation thinking I'm going
to this situation thinking that's a
woman and there's a sexual like a
biological woman yeah a biological woman
and there's a sexual aspect to that
interaction yes that that is not only is
that sa that's to me that's Criminal
what do you guys think ladies
it's a mad situation
you're bisexual does how like how does
it
um yeah I'm bisexual I've Got Friends
from the trans Community none that would
not disclose stuff but that to me is
wild it's unfair because obviously if
you're someone already in the LGBT
community then you're gonna be you may
be more open-minded to these things but
you need to disclose I think it's
important it'll be like someone not
disclosing they've got a whole family or
a wife or these are core things that
need to be discussed
um especially if you're straight so I
mean reporting someone for I mean I
don't know there must be some sort of is
it essay possibly it's very weird like
the thing is you're speaking from you're
speaking from a female point of view
let me ask a question though are we
saying that this person's gone through a
transition or that they're just doesn't
matter yes so let's let's take it to the
extreme just for this argument
dude chopped off his thing
yeah and as has the whole surgery did
everything looks just like like some
something no you look like women yeah
so so so Eddie goes on a date with a
girl
me
okay okay let's say Joe yeah Joe Average
Joe goes on a date with a girl
hanging this girl's out of my lead she's
hot hot right he takes her home after
the date they hook up
he doesn't know that like she's got the
surgery and everything yeah it's wild
um
so is that essay because it's none or a
fraud but is it that it's non-consensual
that the person's not who you thought
they were yeah
I hear what you're saying no I'm asking
exactly I'm asking would you say it is
or it isn't
it is it is but it are you not he there
could be many reasons why you're not who
you say you are ah just don't give
excuses for that it's not an excuse she
asked me a question
right in this moment yeah
it's a very techy situation yeah I'm
sure it happens a lot that's how people
die seriously I don't even want to say
I'm happy you said it yeah that's how
people die because people get [__] up
like doing that [__] I hope I never see
you again rightly so because that
shouldn't that's why yeah like people
actually die like if people get
themselves into really crazy situations
if if you're gonna not disclose the fact
that you are trans and you are gonna
interact with me and I'm thinking that
you are a woman and then I found out
that you're actually not listen that is
a very messy situation for for a
quote-unquote woman to be in that's a
courageous error I'm telling you because
a lot of men will be like what the [__]
is what and you can get yourself into
some serious [__] with that I wonder
what the law is what do you think I
think I think you're right I think you
should just I think they probably should
be disclosing it as well so if they
don't is it a crime
um I don't know I don't know what to say
about that I haven't really got
an answer I don't think it I don't think
they should be done for fraud if I'm
honest I think that's a bit much but um
I feel like that's like because the
other option is great for essay that you
could so say like say if I had a partner
and I was having unprotected sex with
them thinking I was in the committed
relationship but they was cheating
unprotected then then surely that should
be something as well because I'm only
having unprotected sex consensually
thinking it's just us two so if my
partner was having was cheating
unprotected or whatnot then surely that
could be under that as well so so you um
so so you think that a guy lying to
someone about his gender saying that
he's oh no I'm not sure you
you said it's under the house would you
say would you say you think it's it's
similar similar I think anxiety in about
anything to get something that you know
a guy cheated is I know I think lying
about anything anything where you know
there's a chance that if you tell the
truth you're not going to get what you
want then I don't think you should be
doing it no there's levels alone that's
it there's levels there's levels
like I think there's okay
cheating right I I put that but if
you're doing it you're putting someone's
Health at risk okay okay okay so that's
that's wrong right you could argue that
whatever but then then there's there's
not telling someone your gender yeah
this goes can I just say something
before we go into a whole other episode
this is now going into transwise gender
yeah like gender if someone's had a
reassignment then are they this and that
so it's going as a whole different ball
game okay I'll bring it back uh yeah
sorry I'm only just being conscious of
that yeah exactly that's what I was
trying to say that's why you already
lost your Instagram you ever know what's
next
I'll bring it back I've got
um oh basically
um The Guardian was saying it's actually
gone off my phone at the moment the
guardian was saying
um that dating apps are more beneficial
from for a certain caliber of men than
they are for women women generally
get benefit from dating apps but there
are certain as we like to know as we say
on this on the show the top 20 of men is
beneficial for them
um
as women do you think that when you were
under dating app do you think that you
were looking for the same type of man
that every other woman were looking for
um I don't know I don't know what
they're looking for do you know I mean I
just look what I I see what I like it's
not really it is what it is everyone's
got different tastes you know what does
your ideal Man look like high five it
changed I I don't know I haven't really
got a type but if I'm on the estate it
is I don't know I wouldn't say a certain
height that what's the minimum height
that you date my height probably I'm
five five so my heart you better get
your date do you how many okay last last
two three X's how tall were they they um
were like five eight five nine okay so
they were both five eight five nine yeah
about that the
um my first boyfriend was was taller but
the the last two yeah they've been they
haven't been that much taller than me no
but a couple of inches okay but so it
sounds like they're a similar height
yeah but what about saying that I've
been with two of the blow it's like day
two what about what about race same race
no mixed they were they both mixed not
like mixed races but it's just a mix
that I'm not I'm not a racist so I'm up
for
a racist
oftentimes girls like will say they
don't have a type but if I look at their
exes they kind of look the same right
yeah no I get that but then I think
sometimes you can have they might have a
one-off but like usually it'll be like
this guy like similar somewhere one off
similar similar well that only certain
blokes make it past the certain stage
you know I get that it's just my I don't
know I think I'm quite varied with that
I don't think you could look at my day
in history and see a pattern if I'm
honest you know you don't think that
women like the guys that other women
want yes
you don't think we we kind of go for the
same guy like if we walk into if we have
10 guys walk into a room we'll find the
same ones attractive if Eddie walks into
a room right now if Andy walks into a
room right now do you think that most of
the women in the room will be looking at
Eddie
as just as opposed to a man that doesn't
look like Eddie
well expensive
you hear that you hear that hypergamy no
I'm just saying like most of the time
women want uh the guy that other women
want because women essentially like
competition
they that the thing is I think it's it's
not even a conscious thing sometimes it
is but I think sometimes the
subconscious thing I think if if we were
to bring like three other women into
this room right now right
um they would be sizing the ladies up in
this room right they would be like oh
what is her hair like what is she got
makeup on do you know I mean like what's
she wearing like women like competition
like that's how they are and the thing
is they're in that competition because
of men
because they're looking generally
looking for the same guy yeah yeah I
think roller tomasi calls it competition
anxiety right so in that situation yeah
women will come into the room and it's
like
it's it's a game of like who's gonna be
the Lioness in the room type thing right
but then for the guy
if that same guy walks in with let's say
two attractive women then all the women
start to get curious as to why why is he
with those women yeah and why do they
like attractive weird what makes them so
attractive and that's when they start
calculating and trying to understand
what this guy's about so
yeah it's very interesting how I
wouldn't behave in those environments do
you think that I'm curious if you see a
guy
um his ex-girlfriend like you're
interested in a guy and you see his
ex-girlfriend was morbidly obese
and a single mother with three kids from
three different dads does that
does that change your opinion on him are
you equally interested in that changes
my opinion on him because it's about
choices it's about yeah like who what
sort of level have you been operating at
not in a rude way but who have you
chosen to be with that's not necessarily
just based on Aesthetics but if a man is
willing to go with a woman who's got
several fathers to to her children to me
you're not making the choices that are
what what if he met to me like he might
not have any other option right who
would pick then do you need to look at
your choices and how you ended up with
that man yeah or is it that some some
guys will end up with females like it's
easier for them because they like
control or power so if you look at a lot
of relationships that are like
unfortunately like abusive in whatever
way whether that's mentally or
physically is a control element where
they'll go with women who are more
vulnerable who don't have that
confidence who are insecure because it's
easier for them to and bigger girls men
like yeah we're bigger girls get what
they want out of those women I think a
lot of girls in toxic relationships are
toxic themselves views back 100 like I
don't I don't find that it's often like
the vulnerable ones like I I just find
that like it's the equally toxic ones I
think narcissists and there's a lot of
studies on this the narcissists attract
um attract input that in Impact yeah so
that's where that comes from if you've
got someone that then there's numerous
studies about this you can look online
about this there's numerous [__] about
this online
so you see when it comes to like the
whole dating app thing
um it's so crazy to me like actually
looking at the whole data map datar and
the way in which human beings interact
um is it easier to portray yourself what
we already know is it easy to portray
yourself as somebody else and when it's
time
to meet that person if you've guys been
in dating app because I haven't have you
met somebody from a dating app
and then been like this person is
nothing like what they say
I'm talking about the quote-unquote vibe
Vibe I just think social media in
general is all about perception yeah
that perception is king So people do
things to paint a certain perception of
themselves but that may not necessarily
be a reality of the situation I think
when I was when I was studying a
decision in consumer science they call
those a public sphere in a privacy so
now in this digital world people have
multiple
um realities that they can kind of
create for themselves right so there's
there's the digital reality it's like an
avatar it's like an avatar exactly that
so there's a digital reality is that
there's the real world reality right the
digital reality is where you you get the
people on like games like second life
where they've just created this this
fantasy of who they are and what they're
aspiring to be and to some degree they
think that's them and then you meet them
in the real world and it's just it's
nothing like it so the energy in the
vibe is all different
have you ever met a girl that seems
really sweet and then you look at her
Instagram and it's just ass
well I didn't met her in person
you're like no she seems the deception
changes like that literally like that
and then you see like her Instagram and
it's great because that's happened to me
a couple of times on the show where a
girl come in I'm like oh she's such a
sweetie
her Instagram like oh my God like
whatever seriously which makes you like
ask a question why if you are this
innocent cool chill person
in person why do you feel the need to
show that because people are insecure on
the internet and social media makes
people go into this world where they are
competing with each other and majority
of these people are not even happy a lot
of the people that post certain things
they might not even be in joint they're
just going with the crowd because people
don't want to think outside of the
boxing because they feel like they might
be lonely or they're not with the crowd
The In Crowd or this that the other
they're just following suit that of
things that other people are doing well
I think with women women have this like
from from a biological standpoint this
like kind of group mentality so when
they see other women doing certain
things and getting success off it they
feel like you know you need to emulate
that to be in this group and hence the
BBL culture hence the BBL culture make
up blowing up your lips etc etc so you
don't want to be ostracized from any
group and if you see a certain group of
women getting success doing certain
things and you think okay that's what I
need to do to get the man that I want
it's a similar it's the same thing with
what men will say we want natural women
who have natural beauty but in women
will say but you [__] the girl with the
fake bum and the big breasts yes that
was a [__] they're not going to Wi-Fi
and and again we say this on a regular
basis there's certain women that we
there's a caliber woman that would work
on a caliber woman that would wear we
told you the caliber women that we'd
wife but you see what we go for in terms
of just quick interactions and you seem
to assume that that is what men want
whenever the thing is right on on the
flip side of that is because the society
in which we live in is a get
is a have sex culture we are living in
the hookup culture we are living in the
hookup generation right and so the
reason why women are getting confused by
that is because because everybody's
hooking up with each other
um and they're seeing the the people
that are getting the attention for the
hookups women are thinking
I need to do that right but generally
human beings are not looking for
anything long term women I think women
looking through beer goggles because
it's like big you because to me what you
should be paying attention to to the
women that are married and it's not the
ones with bbos and blowing up lips if
you look at the women that are married
they're
they're not even like tens they're like
just like I see it this is where I
disagree this is what's confusing to
women and I I understand like from my
point of view that a lot of times the
girls that are married are just bad
wives but I've had girls on the show
that are married and I look at their
Instagram and they're thoughting it up
on Instagram and it's like men put up
with a lot of [__] and it's because men
are feminized though no no I agree I
agree but I'm saying like there's a lot
of bad like one out of four marriages
are sexless yeah those girls still get a
ring they're sexless I hear that but
then these women don't look like the bbo
like they think the Kim Kardashians
they're not those girls like those are
the girls that men just [__] get rid
of so cool those women exist and they're
doing the madness on Instagram but
they're not the ones who have the the
Cosmetic work done yeah so then would
you say that
um
dating app so strictly
for hookup culture no I
know everything really everything gets
like
absolutely stream to where it can't even
be bloody enjoyed I mean look at [__]
lockdown look how quick people were to
turn into absolute idiots but it's I
think that's happened with that it's
just too the reason why I say that is
because I read from the guardian right
because the guardian says
um data from outside sources suggests
that most people on dating apps are not
finding lost in relationships or
marriages through this platform
I think they had good intentions that
they they probably started off with you
know what we're gonna we're gonna add to
this growing digital age and connect
people in ways that have never been
connected before because what it should
do is facilitate conversation and
actually boost communication but what it
actually does in in connecting people
you're actually separating people at the
same time so what's what's come from
that is that as humans we are
opportunists in whatever we can do for
the men we found a way to have a massive
access to a massive pool of women that
would never would have had access to
before so like if you back in the day
before dating that if you lived in East
London
the maximum women that you're going to
get around is the women in your area now
whether you live in east south
Hertfordshire Liverpool these women are
now all accessible too so so so now it's
it's open the floodgates for people to
just move frivolously it's too much
Choice isn't it that's the thing that's
why no one's picking or or staying
because it's just too much for the women
or for the men
um oh I suppose but if you're going on
it
too what do you mean do you think it's
for the men well they're not but they
have too much Choice as well yeah I
think anything online but I'm saying
that it all depends on the app I see uh
50 I see something on line about Tinder
it was only 15 was women I think that's
wild I think it's a small percentage of
men that don't want to settle down I
think most men want a wife and kids yeah
and most men are pretty realistic with
what they can get I don't find that the
more variety men like I don't find that
most men have that much choice
yeah men women have more Choice than men
as you can as you can probably tell like
as I've always said ladies if you were
to walk out this house right now looking
your quote-unquote bummiest you'd still
get attention from me
but do you just think that's because
Eddie was as a biological driver do you
just think that's because men seek sex
so regardless of or do you think there's
something more to that go on Eddie
see I think men seek sex but at the same
time there's a lot of men who are very
realistic in what it is they're able to
attain so they'll be more than happy to
have one woman he would like
they could cater to indicate it to them
and and they'd be out of the game but
the reality is that most men and even
from a historical standpoint didn't get
opportunity to reproduce so in the
context of a dating app like it
definitely probably favors women more
men would probably want to get more out
of it but they can't we've seen the
stats you know women are swiping 14
whilst men are swiping 67 or something
along those lines so if anything men
probably want relationships more than
women do in those apps but they're not
being but are they being clear about
that
maybe like maybe that's what they feel
like well you've seen the male side so
what what do you see
[__]
as I said I've only twice used these
sites and then it's been a one day you
should download it as as a woman and see
what you get don't don't stop catfishing
what do you mean like Rita like research
purposes and just see their [__]
messages you get bombarded with some of
them are that's the other thing I think
what about Max horrible matchmaking I
think that there's dating apps and then
there's matchmaking sites so I know
someone who's trying to develop an app
where it's more matchmaking based so
e-harmony yeah but then there's an
actual human who tries to match you to
people who have a similar so it may
start with an online platform but then
there's a human element to it where it's
like right do they have the same values
as you right do you you know when you
talk about what era do they live in are
you going to be able to sustain a
relationship when you're living like on
the opposite side of the world and then
they actually provide you with profiles
or people they think might match with
that's a good idea that's more whereas I
started on the Internet or online
there's actually an element of like back
and forth where isn't just you're
swiping saying that do you think like
long distance relationships when it
comes to apps are sustainable no hell no
having a pen power waste of time I think
it's literally just sending nudes back
and forth for that face I think if you
meet someone say if you met someone on
holiday it's a different situation isn't
it you spend like two weeks together or
whatnot that's a bit different like long
term but to start something long term or
you're not even there it seems a bit
much I think just get rid of dating app
to be honest as
just ban
talk
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible